so a lot of people have been talking
about the drama or the wo of Marvel
Studios and the MCU right now there was
a huge Variety article that was put out
that a lot of people were calling a
hitpiece on Marvel with the title
literally being crisis at Marvel
Jonathan Major's backup plans the
Marvel's re- shoots Reviving original
Avengers and more issues revealed
however this article seems to be highly
exaggerated which is why a lot of people
who really know what are going on the
industry insiders are really saying that
it was sort of a hitpiece and a huge
hyperbole just blown way out of
proportion but today forbes.com a huge
highly respected website came out with
an article that is insanely good that is
titled Marvel Studios woses are
overstated which I agree I don't think
Marvel Studios is in that bad of shape
as some people would make them out to be
yes we acknowledge that there are some
flaws and some issues going on right now
but we've always also talked about how
bright the future looks for them with
Deadpool 3 Doctor Strange 3 Kang Dynasty
Avengers Secret Wars the X-Men coming
there are so many great things to look
forward to and this article is a great
article talking about the truth that is
going on right now over at Marvel
Studios so let's dive into this and the
first thing they talk about is Jonathan
Major's as Kang and real quick don't
forget about our giveaway all you got to
do to enter is subscribe and leave a
comment on our videos for a chance to
win a PS5 an Xbox series X some Marvel
Legends items or some DC items the
winner gets to pick one item and we pick
a winner at the end of each month so as
I mentioned the article is titled Marvel
Studios woses are overstated and the
beginning starts off by stating the
variety story and a lot of entertainment
media is really overexaggerating the wo
and the drama over at Marvel Studios
right now and they State the reality is
Marvel's woses are overstated in a media
environment increasingly prone to
hyperbole that's not to say Marvel along
with all Studios and streamers doesn't
face some hurdles going forward but the
nature of those obstacles for Marvel are
frankly pretty obvious Viv it's mostly
things Marvel has overcome before and
regardless of those issues and the need
to address them Marvel is still actually
doing pretty good right now even amid
the problems they've had and I'd have to
agree we've talked about this many times
on the show and on our podcast you can
find that on Spotify and apple podcast
just search The Cosmic Wonder podcast
but we've talked about how Marvel Phase
1 Phase 2 phase three they've not all
been perfect and sometimes we forget
that because overall the infinity Saga
was truly amazing and it ended on the
biggest high note that it possibly could
so going from the biggest high note that
could really be attained by Marvel
Studios into phase 4 which is basically
a restructuring and starting over with
new characters and new content coming
out on Disney plus it's understandable
how people don't think it's as good and
again sure they have problems but these
problems are easily overcomed and Marvel
has done it before the article starts
off by stating so let's unpack what's
really going wrong and what it means for
Marvel Studios they start off by talking
about the situation with Jonathan Majors
talking about how he is supposed to be
the star of several films and streaming
shows and he's the mcu's time traveling
main villain of the Multiverse Saga and
how he's facing multiple accusations of
abuse and is scheduled to stand trial
for one recent case as we all know but
like I've been stating for a while forb
simplifies this and makes it seem pretty
easy and I would have to agree this
situation is a poor situation it really
is it's bad for Jonathan majors and if
he is guilty it's horrible for the
people that he abused but as as far as
Marvel Studios is concerned it's
actually kind of easy they state so yes
Marvel has the choice to recast Kang
lucky for Marvel the character literally
exists across a near infinite number of
alternate realities where he takes
different forms and changes appearances
likewise Marvel has had to recast
characters in the past just like lots of
other franchises or TV streaming Series
this isn't brain surgery and the framing
of this issue as something that could
sink Marvel's whole future plans is
frankly non sense and I would have to
agree because it's pretty simple they
could simply just recast Jonathan Majors
it's not that hard we already know about
variant in the MCU and some can look
different or if they want to get rid of
Kang altogether again there were talks
of bringing Dr dooman which would work
equally as well I think I would prefer
for the whole Multiverse story to stay
the same and them keep King but the main
point here is that this isn't really
that big of an issue we've been talking
about Jonathan Major's possibly being
recast for a while now and that's a
simple solution it sucks don't get me
wrong the whole problem that has arisen
because of this sucks but by no means is
this going to be the end or contribute
to the end of Marvel Studios when they
could simply recast the character and
the article goes on to talk about so
many different characters that could
play the role they mentioned John boa
and they even have a pretty good idea
they say or maybe Denzel Washington as
an iteration of Kang who sat out in the
infighting and Collective efforts of the
rest of the Kings and grew older and
wiser as he made his plans to take over
which honestly I'd kind of liked to see
the point being there are many different
ways to get past this problem there are
many different actors that they could
use to recast and this really isn't a
huge problem for Marvel Studios overall
and the next part is really really
interesting they go into the finances
about everything the box office records
and they break it all down and compare
it to numbers of the past and it's quite
interesting when you look at it and may
not be exactly as bad as you expect it
to be we'll break down these numbers but
first big thank you to Highland titles
for sponsoring this video before we leap
back into the world of superpowers got
something truly extraordinary for our
listeners imagine that you yes you can
become a lord or lady for just $30
buying a plot of land from Highland
titles. will allow you to make use of a
Scottish tradition in which land owners
are given a courtesy title with more
than 15,000 fstar reviews the Highland
titles gift pack is an incredibly
popular gift and the Highland titles app
available from the app and play stores
is a new addition that allows you to
explore a 3D replica of the land choose
the location of your plot and decorate
it using augmented reality embrace the
Majesty as every purchase helps to
conserve the awe inspiring heroic beauty
of the Scottish Wilderness you can soar
into the world of nobility My Friends by
visiting Highland ties.com and become a
lord or lady today use the discount code
Cosmic to receive 25% off your order
that's Highland ties.com and use code
Cosmic so the next part they say so
let's look at the financials now since a
central claim to the Marvel is in
trouble narrative is that the studio is
struggling at the box office while
streaming is an unpopular mess and this
really puts things into perspective for
you at the box office it's true Marvel
hit a high point with its back-to-back
releases of the conclusion to the
infinity Saga Avengers Infinity war and
Avengers endgame they state that
2.79 billion from endgame and 2 billion
from Infinity War elevated the final
Global gross for all 22 films in that
Saga to more than 20 billion for a per
film average of around 935 million in
2018 and 19 the MCU put up the following
numbers black panther hit 1.34 billion
then Infinity War topped 2 billion then
Captain Marvel scored 1.1 billion and
then ingame took 2.79 billion Ant-Man
and the WASP at 622 million is the only
MCU film in those 24 months that failed
to top 1 billion since the infinity Saga
ended Marvel's releases have taken north
of 8.1 billion across 10 movies so far
with a Multiverse Saga per film average
of about
815 million the difference between 885
million and 935 million is not
insignificant but nor is it disastrous
and it's certainly not hard to
understand why it's happening so the
difference in average per film between
the infinity Saga and the Multiverse
Saga is only 120 million again like they
stated not insignificant but not nearly
as much as a lot of people really think
it is a lot of people think that the
Multiverse Saga has just been a complete
disaster at the box office so far but it
hasn't and they even put it in more
perspective stating that the 2018 and
2019 slates for the infinity Saga
benefited from a decade of buildup and
it was those last four out of five total
Blockbusters topping 1 to two billion
each that provided the final heft and
resulted in an even higher per film
average it's basically stating that
those films right before infinity war
and endgame and in between black panther
Captain Marvel and then Infinity war and
endgame itself were all sort of the
buildup and ending to The Infinity Saga
so of course they're going to perform a
lot better than the other movies and
these movies earning so much bumped up
that average per film and we are only in
the first half of the Multiverse Saga to
date and we haven't had a single
Avengers movie in this new saga yet so
of course our per film average for the
Multiverse Saga is going to be lower
right now however as they introduced the
bigger films and the Avengers films that
per film number is going to go up and
that 120 difference is going to decrease
basically what they're stating in this
article is the box office really isn't a
huge issue right now yes some movies
have underperformed in phase four and
Phase 5 but we still have another half
of the entire Saga to go through and
those include movies like Deadpool the
Fantastic 4 and two Avengers films all
of which should perform really really
well and then of course they finished by
stating of course you have to tie in
coid 19 which is true it has definitely
affected things but they go on to say
that the makeup of the top 10 movies
this year looks like this Barbie the
Super Mario Bros movie Oppenheimer
Guardians of the Galaxy volume 3 fast X
Spider-Man across the spiderverse The
Little Mermaid Mission Impossible dead
reckoning part one elemental Ant-Man and
the WASP Quantum Mania so we have three
Marvel movies there in the top 10 movies
of the year so perhaps Marvel fatigue or
superhero fatigue is not really as big
as some people would make us think then
they go want to talk about the Disney
Plus shows and they put this in a good
perspective that I also appreciated they
talk about how Marvel in general during
the MCU not in the MCU has always had TV
shows going on Agents of Shield Agent
Carter in humans Daredevil Jessica Jones
Luke Cage ironfist Defenders Punisher
runaways Cloak and Dagger they've had a
lot of shows out there basically they
State Marvel's had a lot of superhero
shows for a long time during the reign
of the MCU and shows have tended to be
mostly good or get mostly good reviews
or great reviews while often suffering
complaints of inconsistency in tie-ins
versus standalone abilities or iffy
visual effects or questions about who is
in charge and why certain decisions were
made with the series and basically they
are stating does this sound familiar and
yes it does because it's kind of a
broken record of reality at this point
because for the Disney Plus shows that
Marvel Studios has been put out they've
gotten mostly good reviews and some
great reviews yes there have been some
really bad things out there like that
secret Invasion finale a lot of people
complained about She-Hulk but there's
been a lot of good out there like w
division Loki Loki season 2 Miss Marvel
Werewolf by night there's a lot of good
out there but also at the same time
there are pretty serious issues that
need Solutions like the budgets are too
high they are discovering that it's not
sustainable to spend 20 million or more
per episode with rushed production
schedules and unreasonable demands on
the VFX workers combined with my
personal opinion here with bad scripts
those are the biggest options they can't
afford to spend so much money they can't
rush it and they have to Simply write
good stories and the best part is all of
these things are incredibly doable they
can be fixed and overall if you take a
look at all these shows they're working
pretty well so far they haven't all been
absolute Grand Slams they haven't all
knocked it out of the park but overall
it's good and forb states that basically
the truth is more boring than Doom
saying which is why people don't want to
talk about the actual truth a lot and
simply say oh everything's in crisis
everything is failing and what is Marvel
going to do to fix this absolutely
terrible mess that they're in right now
when the truth is it's really not that
hard with Marvel moving forward they
state in the Forbes article Marvel will
recast King they'll reduce the number of
shows and films and production at a
given time they'll get budgets under
control and allow more time for VFX work
and they'll refocus on the approaches
and measures that works so well in the
past to determine which projects to
Greenlight and how to return to the
sense of a big shared World The Avengers
have to team up to save I mean that that
is literally it right there that is what
Marvel needs to do and it's not
complicated it's not a big mess it's
actually quite simple and very very
doable in fact one would say that's
actually pretty easy for Marvel to do
all they have to do is kind of scale
back a little bit which is not hard and
they even end on a really bright note
they State luckily with the X-Men and
Fantastic Four reboots around the corner
Marvel has a couple of big teams with
lots of potential for precisely the sort
of story storytelling Marvel does best
at the Blockbuster level they could even
simply move toward a post secret War
setup that lets Fantastic 4 X-Men and a
handful of other existing popular
franchises carry the Marvel Brand
forward for a while and check this out
they even say we will also probably see
the temporary return of Robert Downey Jr
Chris Evans and Scarlett Johansson
reprise their popular MCU roles for
Avengers the King Dynasty Andor Avengers
Secret Wars so even Forbes is talking
about the return of of these awesome
characters and actors and they even say
that the Slate coming up like I
mentioned in the beginning Deadpool 3
the Fantastic 4 The Avengers films
Captain America Brave New World these
are all really big movies that are
likely to be blockbuster hits which I
agree so Marvel Studios is not really in
that big of trouble right now things
aren't exactly as big of a mess over
there that a lot of people would have us
think which is great news and I would
have to agree and like they said the
solution is pretty simple recast Kang
get the budgets under control and get
more time for the VFX work scale back
and do what you did before to make
everything return to the sense of a big
shared world that the Avengers have to
team up to save there it is that's the
solution but let me know what you think
about all of this in the comments down
below do you agree with this do you not
let us know don't forget to like the
video and subscribe so you can stay up
to date on all the latest Marvel and MCU
news you can find us on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof
woof